we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
hello welcome to we might be drunk yeah
gobble gobble
look i got my grandma's uh
arm fat going
look at this this is a full-on turkey
baby it's great we had a native american
but sam gave him smallpox
so he's not here but hey man we got our
buddy tom takar hey
i think we got screwed on this deal i
think you got the nice one that looks
much more comfortable yeah it is pretty
come it's velvet here feel that that's
nice i mean this is some some prime
turkey i knew you were a little i i felt
a little resentful that i got to be uh
woody and you were buzzed oh
yeah i wanted to be woody but
i feel like i'm redeemed i'm back i mean
i could wear this to bed that's nice
this is very nice is this amazon matt
uh he's not listening all right i bet
it's amazon and we got the bear jewel
back i don't even know what you're
drinking what are we doing here don't
forget to stay over there oh you got to
hook me up brother we're doing this
since this thanksgiving it's getting a
little colder
we're doing
uh
a hot apple cider spice hot potato
hot apples
toddy hey look at that hey to america
so clear up the uti let's do it
i'm shocked you didn't use a little wild
turkey
dude that is incredible that's so good
oh my god what makes it what's giving it
that little pop oh
honey in there right and we heat it up
with some uh cinnamon sticks and star
anise that's what it is a little bit of
orange and a little lemon
delightful i need this and it's caramel
apple cider too oh my god i mean you've
heard of such a thing i'm gonna drink
this when i'm sick like it actually
doesn't help it actually does help if
you're feeling under the weather yeah
it'll clear you up do you think that
helps that's like alcoholic talk right
there it's every time i do something
like that i'm like i have a problem
yeah do it i'll be like i switched to
hot toddy's it'll be good when i had
covet i was doing [ __ ] like that what
yeah only the last couple days i
couldn't i couldn't have covered for i
had i didn't have the long i had uh i
had the regular coven but i had it for
like it was like nine days of it being
brutal ugh and i kept being like oh it's
great i'll be like on vacation i like
had booze ready to go you're gonna be on
vacation because i had to take all my
spots off and i was like oh this is a
great this would be great i'll watch all
i watched mad men watched a bunch of
[ __ ]
top to bottom i finished it i it took me
10 years to watch mad men such a good
it's so good but it's so
slow that's why you wanted to drink yeah
yeah yeah that show made me want to
drink dude it was brutal i was watching
them drink all the time i was like that
looks so fun but i couldn't do it i
physically couldn't do it i don't know
how they do it yeah they were doing that
on work days it'd be like 11 30 and they
would just clink two glasses together
and make a deal yeah but you know what
those were that it made you want to work
yeah because you're like oh i got a
meeting you're like but we'll have
[ __ ] oysters and martinis i know it
was a better time not knowing when [ __ ]
was bad like they didn't know cigarettes
were bad they didn't know booze was bad
you know you ate a burger it was all you
must
i don't think you wake up from a
hangover at 45 from vodka and you're
like that was that was probably true but
the smoking they didn't know i think
they thought it was like good for you
yeah they were like yeah you gotta you
need a cigarette like in the hospital
you're like they're giving it to kids
come on have a little nah you know the
vibrator was invented because a woman uh
it was for like female hysteria
was that right give it a goog oh this
guy's not even on the cans
look that up matt vibrator was invented
for women with hysteria because
apparently the first doctors would do it
manually no no no and then after really
they got a carpal tunnel
doctor used to be a great gig craig is
smoking fingering
what's her name gladys [ __ ] yeah you go
to the hospital it's not usually a bunch
of babes in the bed yeah good point good
point
i don't know i had an orthodontist when
i was a kid and all the nurses were like
11's and he was like some old guy with
white hair but i guess he got to pick
the nurses yeah true that's weird to
pick a nerd
it's not like being a waitress like they
kind of have to bring it yeah yeah it's
weird
that's a good point you need them to be
good at what they're doing a little bit
uh yeah read this what is this joseph
granville patented an electro mechanical
vibrator in the early 1880s to relieve
muscle aches and doctors soon realized
it might be used on other parts of the
body the innovation treatment but
treatment for hysteria
wow there you go same deal with
fleshlights yes
this man's hysterical
you ever used one i
i bought one when i was i bought one you
bought one i bought when i was blackout
drunk which is not true because i
remember doing it
[Laughter]
that used to be a bit of my but this is
true after my i got engaged when i was
like 21. it fell apart i went to i moved
back to my hometown i became i started
drinking all the time and my house was
like a five-minute walk from the bar and
along that walk was a porn store oh of
course it's called college books because
students would go there buy porn and
they didn't want their parents credit
card wow
it's smart but
i
i bought an eight dollar uh
like fake vagina and yeah they told me
to buy lube and i was broke at the time
i was like [ __ ] your upsells or whatever
i got it back to my place and it was
disgusting and so i tried third degree
burns on your [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] it it
was painful it looked like one of those
like tubes
it's like got the gel in it or whatever
that you want like the carnival or
whatever and i didn't i couldn't do it
and then i rolled it up into a towel and
forgot about it and then when me and my
buddy were moving it was in my dresser
the drawer fell out i was moving with
his dad yeah and it fell out and it felt
the towel fell on the ground
on the driveway and the [ __ ] thing
unrolled and the fake vagina just rolled
down into the
into the into the driveway and he just
didn't say anything but yeah
real vaginas could make such a graceful
exit right
wow yeah i mean i'm guilty of [ __ ]
everything in the house as a kid right
the couch the bed the foods all kinds of
[ __ ] mm-hmm
anything that like was like look like a
hole that would be like oh that's cool
like even like in fences yeah you're
like oh i bet might get sticking in
there because it's exactly a paper towel
holder that was a big one paper paper
towel holder seems like it'll be great
too because you could just put like a
napkin at the end of it it's like clean
up and you throw it away but it's just
too bad they should make paper towel
holders like the the thing like softer
yeah i know right yeah bounty get on
that [ __ ] yeah the quilted quicker
picker-upper
act like
you know i remember watching scared
straight when i was younger there was
one guy like i can make the best [ __ ]
you ever filmed
with paper towels a couple of this
little that like some jelly this and
that he's like you will never need a
woman again
you've been in here 30 years you're just
gay
yeah yeah this is good and it gives you
something to do with the roll because
you got to just throw that away it's
over yeah this is like what's good for
the environment it's green that's true
yeah
yeah
the guy who makes the vagina that's
pretty rough yeah yeah yeah because
you're like what is what are you using
like what is your
test like yeah what is your research
you're the dude you don't have people
being like you're not [ __ ] trying it
on mice right you're the you're the lab
do you think you'd go gay how long would
it take in prison to do the the shower
sex
not like put on you i know some guys
will pin you up against
just try to find like a nook and say
that but after seven years
what did i what crime did i commit here
i will say grand theft auto grand theft
auto so you're in there for a good 15.
how long would it i mean it's nothing
it's not like i'm anti-gay i just don't
think
i don't think i do it i don't know i
don't know but you ever in a club in
college you're like oh there's no hot
girls in this class then you by the
third week you're like well you know
sure she's on a rascal but she's got
nice eyes and then he just started it
just starts weaning it out casino did
you go to college
[Laughter]
i think in between the thumbprint and
getting booked yeah i'd go gay right
immediately
yeah you don't know but yeah i think i
would just like hope to get magazines
oh yeah yeah you know they said
cigarettes were the number one currency
in jail and now it's ramen noodle
what yeah
why is that flipped i don't know i guess
you'd rather eat than smoke yeah but
you'd think it would be a better food or
something at least because isn't that
like the shittiest well you're not
getting uh you know cheddar bay biscuits
in there
people will do the uh the seasoning and
just eat them raw nice do that yeah
in a squid game they're doing that and
that there's have you seen squid game
yet yeah yeah it's good game they're
eating the guy's just eating the ramen
dry like a snack with the thing it's
like people love that looks terrible
yeah i'd give it a shot yeah yeah i'm a
big cup of noodles fan this is fantastic
yeah again i'm i'm gonna warn you i
might fly through these
i got more than enough nice i gotta out
of the gate i gotta say that i love you
wearing a carmella soprano shirt yeah my
it's my buddies uh this man wild pink
check them out oh nice yeah they is that
their logo carmela they just put that on
their shirt and i was like that is
brilliant because i like the music and
then i was like oh but i [ __ ] love
that shirt
you don't even need to yeah yeah there
we go still the best show oh it's so
good mad men and sopranos this is this
is a we might be drunk episode we're
talking about those two shows yeah
that's true so good somebody made a
drinking game out of our show
so it's a rodney impression i fart
uh so many of our directions turned into
like it's like steel toilet paper and
you can get free copper off the railroad
tracks
mark's still stealing despite making a
ton of money mark's doing right on the
road that's a hobby it's like
it's like stealing the holy fans thing
like wait kanye steals only fans off for
reddit he said he like he doesn't pay
for only vans is like you gotta act poor
to stay rich hey mark's on the tip yeah
you don't
kanye's got
i think he just probably doesn't respect
porn no
that's what it is yeah yeah yeah for
sure but
i mean i've never paid i'm a drama mean
guy at the airport because it helps me
sleep on the plane
it's like 18 dollars for motion sickness
i know but it's so drowsy
inducing benadryl something like that
yeah yeah but you don't get any you
don't get like a hangover from it or
anything so i pop a couple dram meet on
a plane but they're like 18 for a little
tube that's crazy because it's the
hudson news so they upsell everything up
charge and uh i've never paid for one
i've you just swipe it from the airport
every time you swipe dude every time i
thought about you the other day because
i saw someone get busted for shoplifting
at the airport yeah and it was so
embarrassing i don't know what they
stole it might have been like a bag or
something it was an old woman
just like four cops are surrounding her
and it looks so embarrassing
[Laughter]
about you when you get that old you know
you gotta stay in the pocket when you're
stealing mm-hmm even if it is the news
you got to really be they got to finesse
i think about doing it all the time
especially at the like the food places
where you're just
it's selfie or whatever i'm always like
i could just walk i think i've done i
did it with coffee once just to feel
something you know but yeah
because i can you know i got i could pay
for coffee but yeah it's fun
get away with something exactly because
they're already over charging your ass
on everything else so [ __ ] you know
you're going to charge me for a bag now
jet blue blow me i'm stealing this drama
mean but what i do it's not them though
it's the airport isn't it
you take a like a wrap those wraps are
like nine dollars it should be two and
then i put a napkin over it kind of
looks like a receipt then you play with
it under the uh the self-checkout you go
you know you're just kind of waiting
it's a money thing i think you do enjoy
the stealing i do i'm getting one over
on them
yeah it's nice to get a little back i do
that like i know you hop turn styles
yeah yeah there's nothing more
satisfying than hopping it as the train
comes
after cobit i was like oh i don't use
the train as much as i used to i'm not
buying a monthly anymore [ __ ] now and at
my stop because i i live in bed stuy so
people will just be holding the door
open all the time and i roll through
there and i'm like every time
but they're with the criminals
i love it you feel like the coolest
white guy too when you're holding the
door open all these guys are coming
[Music]
me too and i was just holding the door
open for a buddy who was trying to pay
the machines were all [ __ ] up and they
still got us we got the only time i've
ever gotten a ticket from a i've been
handcuffed a couple of times but the
only time i've actually gotten a ticket
was uh i was with my friend dan who
bartends to the cellar now we were kids
yeah walking down the street and uh
we're just drinking on the street and
these cops gave us summons and dan's got
a million of them so he's laughing
they're just like all right well now
that you've uh now that you've had the
uh the ticket you can finish the beer
and dang goes yeah i know that i know
the deal
[Music]
i love that because [ __ ] i hate that
they do that [ __ ] i gotta i gotta you
know
i got a drinking ticket i think i'm the
only person who got a public drinking
ticket during covid because i was at my
friend's backyard i was walking over the
course it was like 10 o'clock at night
i'm at my apartment i'm like outside the
door of my apartment and this cop goes
is that a beer and i was like yes
who cares kind of square of coffee
he [ __ ] like gets in my face and i
was like you know i was a little toasty
and i was like i was like put on a mask
man you're in my you're kidding me yeah
and he was like where's your mask
where's your mask and i was like i
didn't know you were gonna [ __ ] bum
rush me i'm alone in the street i don't
need a mask but uh then he hassles me
for [ __ ] 30 minutes i'm outside of my
door and i'm like dude it's a 25 ticket
just give me the [ __ ] ticket and move
on and he's like how many ounces what's
the percent of alcohol
it's a [ __ ] course who cares yeah
then it's a it's the same fine no matter
how many ounces it is it's 25 bucks
it's absent
it's three grand yeah
what is this the airport we gotta do out
this is nice it was insane and then he
goes uh i had two more unopened cores
and he goes you can keep those and i was
like yeah i know it's my problem
he made me dump out the the chords in
front of him though uh so pissed i had
the same thing but this is pretty
because i thought covert made beer
legalized i thought so too yeah yeah
because we were all drinking they're
doing the sidewalk it's so weird it's a
sidewalk cafe and drink beer but if
you're two feet from the sidewalk cafe
yeah remember russ maniv used to do the
joke about uh you you can drink uh in
the in the garbage bag
yeah the garbage but you can't do it
outside he's like by the way you can't
just like [ __ ] a prostitute in a hefty
bag
[Music]
what are you doing here not so fast
officers just taking out the trash
absolutely
russman
another class he goes i have bad luck
with women my last four pregnant
girlfriends died in sailing accidents
that's a great joke that's really good
smart russ has some bangers yeah i think
he's got an album out there uh check out
doggy style is that it yeah that's what
it's called oh that didn't age well
but i got hassled by a cop on the lower
east side once i had a couple of beers
on me and i was drinking with my
ex-girlfriend and he did the whole like
oh you guys drinking it we're like ah no
and he's like what's that i was like
that's a beer and he goes well why'd you
lie to me i was like because you're a
cop yeah yeah you wanna get in trouble
why do you think i would lie to you yeah
i'm not a
jerk when we were kids too we were you
know smoking weed in the street i'm
rolling a joint like a stoop and uh
these cops
my friends are all [ __ ] cowards they
all they i'm like we are what are we
doing so we they run them they're faster
to notice the cops i'm like [ __ ] i'm
trapped with two of my friends and the
cops start questioning us and of course
i'm thinking so i had two bags of weed
at the time i just [ __ ] threw them in
the sewer real quick
but i'm like yeah it was better than
what i would what happened back then you
know yeah and uh
you know and i had cigarettes on me too
thank god so they're just like what are
you doing i was like oh i didn't know it
was uh against the law to smoke
cigarettes officer and he's like why'd
all your friends run i was like because
of the movies
and he was like oh he was like the
nicest cop i've ever met he was like oh
he's like a nice irish guy he's like all
right and he's like well uh i was like
can i smoke cigarettes he's like of
course and have a good evening he was
like that nice wow yeah that is nice my
friends were like you [ __ ] talked
your way out of it i was like i mean we
only had cigarettes on us yeah what are
they gonna bust us for man you're like
the
the narcotics guy you got weeds
cigarettes and booze you got all the
stuff you got what's that what's the
word for that cbs no no
contraband that's the word i was looking
for contraband whatever that means
i do need to refill it yeah i'm about to
do right now i'm going to heat up some
more cider yeah
is the microwave being used in this we
got a little kettle too oh happy
holidays
dude it's the move oh yeah last year me
and my buddies got like a cabin or like
a little house in vermont and we were
buying all this like this you know
organic cider on the side of the road oh
yeah i would take it back to the place
and put bourbon in it and heat it up oh
my god incredible nothing like a cabin
with the gang that's a nice with your
your pals you're at a cabin you ski all
day and you're drinking you actually
like that i feel like you wouldn't like
that i did it with chrysler and ahri and
rana zizi a couple a couple guys last
year we went skiing and then we did a
show at night i was about to feel like
you'd still find a spot in the middle of
nowhere yeah we did we went to wise guys
but then we go to park city
when it's all comics we're all hungry to
do a set as
talking like well days like we're doing
mushrooms
that's not your thing yeah i did
mushrooms too and it helped having the
stand up in the middle but
mark can't shut it off i get it i feel
guilty like if i take a day or two off
but it's like sometimes it's nice when
everybody's just like no [ __ ] we're
all committing we're just gonna be here
get drunk smoke weed do mushrooms and do
nothing and it's great and yeah just
laugh the hardest you've ever laughed
it's the best terrified to do mushrooms
oh you gotta do it oh you gotta do we
gotta do it
we should do it no no way i did it for
the first time during the painting we
act well with two weeds i don't either i
like wheat i like i like alcohol because
it quiets the stuff sure i got some some
micro dose we can start you with one see
how you feel then keep going and the
whole thing lasts four hours you'll be
done that's what's great about mushrooms
no no you mean just a little longer than
the movie titanic
that's it we could do two episodes and
you'd be sober i think this is great i
think this is a great idea
because i i don't i'm not a big weed guy
either it makes me too crazy i get
scared mushrooms are way more fun
because your whole body's into it you
look at a tree for an hour you're like
this is great
but i only did like 2.2 grams or
whatever so it's like
not a ton you know or like even a gram
and a half or something like that i'm
doing little i'll bring in some gummies
and by the way we got to celebrate
because somebody gave me a bunch of
mushrooms and i threw them in my bag i
forgot about it i've been traveling with
mushrooms this is for six months i
forgot about it don't you isn't that no
one but no one's the type of
[ __ ] i fly with weed on accident all
the time
they don't care they can't give a gun
uh and i've been flying with a gun
[Laughter]
we gotta celebrate man yeah yeah we'll
bring it up we'll bring a gun and we'll
shoot it up in the air we'll do drugs
and bring guns a russian roulette
yeah it's weird now the alec baldwin
thing every time i watch like you're
like you see watch like malcolm x when
denzel
and you're like someone could have blown
their head off during the scene like
yeah
i'm shocked this [ __ ] doesn't happen
earlier like the gun thing like the the
travis scott thing the people got
crushed yeah i'm like how has that not
happened a million times
we don't have that bigger fan base well
that too yeah that's why i don't know
tickets
we lose nine fans it's gonna financially
impact us
that's true we'll notice it we'll feel a
dip but i'm just saying like all these
like heavy metal and all this [ __ ] like
you'd think that would happen all the
time like there's mosh pits where people
just swing at each other and it's so
shocking is the first time i hate [ __ ]
like that that's why i don't i like live
like i would go to live music that was
like not at all like that heavy metal
was like i don't want to be like bumping
up yeah
i don't want to be that close to someone
i don't know
i don't like the invasion of your space
no and they're like actively trying to
you know bump each other and swing at
each other you don't get it at all i
don't know and i like some like [ __ ]
that's a little bit hard sometimes and i
stand in the very back yeah i don't need
to be part of that [ __ ] no
that's some that's some 18 year old [ __ ]
yeah yeah and then you're like well if
that's who the music is for then it
might not be for us
right right
give me something to break
it's a weird lifestyle would be great if
they just get on stage and start beating
the [ __ ] out of him yeah he's gonna give
me something to break your jaw would be
yeah thanksgiving though it's gonna be a
good one oh it's gonna be a good one are
we releasing this on thanksgiving day or
we can do sunday be kind of fun to drop
this on thanksgiving day what do you
think peter's going out early what do
you think
i don't know whatever sunday that is so
this is before thanksgiving or the sun
this would be the sunday afternoon so it
would be nice to throw it out on
thanksgiving day
thanksgiving
don't have family to be with to
something to listen to dude
podcast family before oh we could do
that we could do the sunday before what
do you think
yeah that's not bad maybe the monday i
don't know just give it a little closer
to thanksgiving but i don't want to piss
off the fans with a day late
again
yeah who gives a [ __ ] yeah it's all free
to [ __ ] him
not [ __ ] the fans but [ __ ] their and
they're mad i'm saying that's free i
think about that with my pot all the
time i'm like i'm making so little money
to do this if you're mad at me like i'm
doing this for
the just the labor of love exactly
yours is fun stand by your face i did
that yeah leonard cohen i did leonard
i got a ton of [ __ ] you leonard cohen
get out of here
same as a young leonard cohen yeah the
teacher really seems to care
it's such a great premise it's a great
idea
man who would you do mark
uh who would you defend yeah who do you
get made fun of for liking i love van
morrison and everybody calls me a cheese
dick because he's so sappy
but i love him i got van morrison on my
on my playlist pre-show playlist oh nice
baby please don't go
that's good i like your pictures
she said it was great seinfeld loved it
too oh it's crazy i think he's the
coolest guy there's ever maybe i think
he's so [ __ ] cool yeah tommy mcnamara
the coast of my pod i know you went on
yeah
yeah yeah we went on basketball videos
on twitter
can we play one of his basketball videos
i'm pissed about the last one that he
got cooking because i shot it but i had
the best basketball day of my life that
day i could not miss that one [ __ ]
video of me nobody does it you and i we
cooked uh we cooked gold in that day man
it's good yeah coleman's very good but
we were on we had tom had his three ball
going i got the three ball going i have
my bank shot locked up oh it was nasty
thank you couldn't handle it sammy
koppelman was there too sammy's good
yeah that was a fun day we gotta get
back out there i talked to goldman he
was like oh i play at six in the morning
in harlem and i was like i can't [ __ ]
do that oh come on i know his texture
like meet me at 1 45th
at 7 30 in the morning i'm like none of
those things are doable for me right now
but
i've never seen this yeah that's good no
this is not no
it's tommy mcnamara what is what is this
if you go to his twitter tommy mcnamara
yeah um
great twitter it might be hard to uh
youtube
i don't know if you just look up tommy
mcnamara basketball you might be able to
find it the problem is tommy is uh tommy
mcnamara is also a famous soccer player
so oh no yeah he's kind of [ __ ] yeah
uh that's what happened to you i know i
know i know he was tom brady
i had to change it up
because you could not google me man
that's now i'm all over the place i had
one drink
i'm all over the place it happened there
he is
wow okay
he hit the rim on one i love it the
thing is tommy is sneakily much better
than you would think he would be
uh he's he's but he's doing this on
purpose
i don't think he's necessarily doing
this on purpose i mean let's see let's
see
there's one where he's throwing it
behind his head and the ball comes back
and smashes his phone and breaks it
it's great
oh i remember that yeah
there was more of these i mean some of
these
send it to me real fast
uh that's not him no that's him that's
awesome
[Applause]
it's so funny because he talks so much
[ __ ] in these two it's great you guys
gotta watch them they're they're really
fun
what's the myth now [ __ ]
remember that scene with uh
phillip seymour hoffman all right yes oh
my god how long came
i do that all the time it's one of my
favorite comedy bits yeah and it's
[ __ ] philip seymour awesome the guy
had so much range it's so hard to be
funny yeah that scene is hilarious
we've all recreated it every time you go
on the basketball court and miss i
wonder if i wonder how much uh work he
put into that because he clearly put so
much work into his uh
but his son is now in uh the new year
pta right thomas anderson and one of the
uh he's just a cool guy yeah thomas
anderson oh yeah oh yeah he's the real
deal i mean although i'll say i think
his best movies boogie nights still
boogie nights is the most fun by far
because like you know there will be
blood is awesome but it's heavy it's not
fun yeah boogie nights is like this is
great you guys got a big dick philip
seymour hoffman's gay
riley's funny it's awesome dude
it's uh yeah that movie i i knew a guy
who was an extra in that movie uh there
will be blood and he was like yeah
daniel day lewis did not shut it off and
it was [ __ ] terrifying that seems
brutal yeah yeah
bring me a
like oh my god
he's a little intense
have you did you guys talk about this on
here where it's like it's never
somebody if people do that method acting
[ __ ] it's always an [ __ ] it's never
like oh he was really nice the whole
time
it's never like rob schneider was a
european gigolo the whole shoes
he really was yeah
tom hanks became mr rogers that's super
cool he would do tom hanks interview on
bill simmons pretty good oh yeah he
never does like those types of
interviews but uh pretty cool we talked
about
simmons is obsessed with castaway so
it's a lot about castles
i didn't know that movie took
that long two years or something well
they shot
they shot the two things separate i
think they shot him heavier first and
then
of course it was like a year apart but
no movie had done something like that if
he shot him heavier first
or yeah i would go the other way if i
were him
bulk up
yeah he does yeah well he's on the
island second i think no no he had he
had time to lose all that weight right
but that whole year's gotta suck now
yeah that sucks i think he also had to
like throw the beard out and he was
shooting another movie at the same time
so they had to like reverse it
[Music]
yeah it usually goes the other way you
usually have to gain weight for a roll
well i guess the machinist yeah and ty
and matt damon all the superhero ones
they got to like bulk up that's true
i'm assuming the studios like here's a
trainer and you're like yeah i would
[ __ ] oh yeah this is like part of the
pay this is great yeah
yeah i know and it's so hot yeah so hot
and then it's just like pictures haven't
played video games and stuff and i was
like i would love that life like right
trainer video games i know you don't
have to do comedy anymore
yeah more like weird up making movies is
like one of the only ways people get
thin because you know other people like
i'm trying to lose weight it's not easy
but if you put you in a movie we could
do it because you'd have to get a
trainer and everything yeah you should
cast everybody on that like 600 pounds
yeah just put them in a minute
blockbuster film right
that show is so depressing i can't watch
[ __ ] like that i can't either i used to
go to aldi lang's house and we would
watch it
and already already narrating that show
is maybe the funniest thing about so
[ __ ] fun
is back and he's doing his podcast
so that's awesome so go support already
because i love that guy i really i
really love that i do too i'm a fan and
and it's not my job i think it's already
mantis but he said i can't believe
already lang outlived nor macdonald
which is so such a good boy so i can't
believe bob dole lived nor mcdonald's
yeah right i mean that's crazy
terrible oh yeah because he did bob dole
yeah damn great that's crazy all right
pete norman
favorite of all time he's your number
one oh number one number one i still top
three whenever i'm on the road i'm like
in a [ __ ] mood or whatever i'm just
like i don't feel like doing anything
i'll just watch him on youtube for
whatever amount of time
whenever i have something fun to play or
like an important thing to do i'll watch
him just reading the man great
the ads it's so funny
those guys are animals but as far as
googling and like a youtube wormhole
norm is hard to beat because he's got
the stand up he's got the weakened
update
all that [ __ ] yeah probably no one's
better a panel oh yeah no it's non-stop
like he's he has so many clips he's
non-stop funny there's never a moment
that you're watching where you're like
oh norm was a little off on this one
like he's always funny it's it's great
you ever be people who don't like norm
they're like oh really you're like come
on dude when he died and people were
saying oh my god what are you talking
about
being like i'm not it was like an old
article there's a whole article being
like i understand that he's good but it
doesn't do it for me i'm like yeah you
know what that's called instead of an
article is uh keeping it to yourself
yeah why did you have to and also say
that five years ago why did you do that
right after that i [ __ ] needed it
yeah when people are [ __ ] coping with
it it's like okay now i've made
something people will click on oh it
made me hate it that sucked
yeah i got i got a good ten thousand
hours for you being a [ __ ] human
being
for ten thousand hours
that was the tipping point for me
jesus christ i didn't know about that
he's supposed to be a smart guy yeah and
it's like it's i didn't even finish it
because it's like the whole point was
like i listened to the comedians who do
love him and they're no more than me
it's like then why the [ __ ] did you
write this
yeah it's like saying i'm wrong but
here's still what i feel it's so funny
like pissed off
yeah you don't like him that's cool yeah
it's me it's not it's not cool
but you don't have to make it a whole
thing and it's especially the day after
he died or whatever yeah
no
norm was
the panel god i mean there was no one
like him yeah at walking that line and
and truly man conan doesn't get enough
credit for being i mean look everyone
knows conan's great but like he is
incredible at uh at setting you up he's
he's a point guard he's yes he's [ __ ]
chris paul just making you look good out
there he really is great straight man
and he would lead you on by looking
disturbed he'd be like what are you
talking about and then norm would keep
going oh so have you guys listened to
the conan like tribute episode oh my god
that was horrible but hearing him talk
about the moth bit
i immediately i was listening to the car
with my lady and i was like we have to
listen we have to you have to hear the
moth bed now
to understand the context of how funny
this is but he's just like and you now
watching that clip you watch norm's eyes
because he didn't know he was gonna have
to do that segment ah and then he talked
about it on kona he was like conan was
like i surprised norm by being like
we're keeping you for an extra
seven minutes so norm is we his wheels
are spinning because he doesn't know he
had to be on for another seven minutes
with nothing planned so he pulls out
this [ __ ] joke that he heard colin
quintel the moth joke and he has to
stretch that bit into seven minutes you
see his eyes moving around it's
incredible i it's you gotta listen to
that and then watch that bit it's so
good yeah conan uh he really
he's so he's so good at like
keeping the momentum in the air too
he'll get jokes in there without taking
away from whoever the guest is which is
not easy to do yeah that's true yeah
yeah norm's the best colin quinn said
the two funniest hangs are norm and
spade going at it yeah i mean you can
see it when yeah when spade is on norm's
podcast it might be the best podcast
there's ever been it's so funny it's
non-stop and spade's like oh god
it works it works spade and normal
dennis miller those episodes are
incredible yeah i've never seen that
earlier
i got to see that you got it
no i'm just [ __ ] with them the whole
time it's great it's pretty funny man i
wish we'd pull that up but it would take
too long but yeah it's soaked watch that
when you get home
we got to do some thanksgiving right
this is a thanksgiving episode
thanksgiving i mean we're dressed as
pilgrims for [ __ ] sake
turkey
here's another thing about canto
when is a white guy finally going to
talk about people getting cancelled
as a turkey i'm offended
it's always as as a woman as a black guy
no one gets cancelled more than turkeys
that's true true only one gets pardoned
every year or whatever right it's kind
of [ __ ] up yeah that's going to be
[ __ ] up with that yeah
the
yeah it's torture you're like you get to
live but you have to watch all your
friends
yeah turkey maybe the best sandwich made
you think it's interesting
i'm gonna go pastrami on that one whoa
pastrami it's so heavy
it's true it's a day ender that i it
depends on how you do it because this is
a this is i was gonna i was maybe gonna
do this as a wreck even because i bought
yesterday i bought turkey and i bought
pastrami i bought i just i put like one
slice of pastrami on some bread and it's
incredible people the problem with
ordering pastrami at a restaurant is
they give you a stack of them yes that's
right
pastrami reuben
dude you're gonna give me a heart attack
just talking about it no i mean if you
go to like one of those classic cats's
or any of those classic delis and you
get like corned beef or pastrami it's
it's it's so but if i'm going like
normal day i yeah turkey with a little
cheddar mayo that's a classic new york
sandwich or i'll do a little you know
even a turkey burger chicken breast i
like to go a little lighter because it's
like usually a lunchtime yeah exactly
i'm trash so i uh when i'm trying to
lose weight i just buy turkey and i just
eat the tur i i know it's real bread
loose turkey and that's my meal
i want the i want the turkey breast i
don't want that [ __ ] processed
nitrate yeah yeah i want the real target
the slicer
i didn't start doing that until like two
years ago
dude it's it feels incredible
it'll change your life because you ask
the guy you just confidently order and
he does it and you're like what the [ __ ]
did i just do what is it like eight
hundred dollars for a slice
it's not it's it's not more expensive
yeah it's slightly more expensive than
like doing like hormel or something the
hormone is trash you gotta stop the
hormones
you know what i love about pastrami and
the turkey is that those ends i love it
i want to do this
because they season the [ __ ] out of them
oh it's so
good i do that salsalito turkey it's so
good man i do love a little pepper
turkey yellow honey turkey turkey
turkey honey turkey all day with a
little a little i'll do i'll mix up the
cheeses i'll get a little [ __ ]
sometimes i'll do gouda sometimes i'll
do cheddar sometimes
good show monsters like the william h
macy of cheese
always delivers but it's not talked
about enough yeah here here
i like to have married
[Laughter]
it's funny you see that scene in fargo
and you're like oh this is like his life
oh my god you're wrong
i know happens there's a talk about it
they have all this real tape uh from the
people who are talking to the that guy
who was fixing the college like uh what
do you call it like who was fixing their
[ __ ] to get them in or whatever they
have him talking about like yeah and
we'll just pretend they're on the diving
team or whatever and they have the audio
and you hear the people you hear the
people getting nervous on the phone
they're like i don't really want to talk
about this that much on the phone what
you know
you know what the deal is and it's like
they have all the audio it's insane
that's terrifying i got to find the name
of this
you're like
jesus
yeah lori laughlin man she's aged
incredibly well so is john stamos
whatever's in that house
it doesn't look bad at all it looks good
i know coulier looks all right they look
all right yeah well have you actually
seen coolio in a minute
no i i just think uh
probably being rich for 30 years helps
that's uh yeah chris rock said uh rich
is the best lotion yeah yeah dude i mean
look at this looks insane it's crazy
he's so [ __ ] hot
uh wait what was i gonna say about uh oh
the lori laughing thing bugs me a little
because uh i thought that was part of
getting make it in america was you get
you know you get little perks like free
cops what's the difference between going
to usc and like [ __ ] uc santa barbara
like it's all [ __ ] the same [ __ ]
you're rich anyway your kids are set up
yeah your kids don't even [ __ ] need
to go to college yeah like if there's
ever been a scam she's married to like
some massive designer like her money
comes from her husband who's a designer
who's the husband
look i don't know pull it up man i don't
know
what that guy yeah i had those cargo
shorts
i forgot about massimo
is that the same guy
when your life is already a shortcut you
don't need more shortcuts i think that's
the point they're making i see but is
that jail worthy
i mean what did she do two months in a
[ __ ] yeah it's not like it was real
her prison was like being in delta one
it was still it was still fine i mean
you're in the air but you get a good
you probably probably like you're
probably like getting healthy you're
probably like right yeah i'll do yoga
i'll do pilates sometimes
like i it would be nice to go to jail
for like that type of prison for like a
month or you're like well every day i'm
gonna work out i'm gonna be so [ __ ]
bored i might read a couple books like
yeah yeah it's the same as like getting
a like a spa or a trainer you gotta go
in and get [ __ ] get in shape you know
you can't watch tv you can't look at
your phone it's like almost good for you
it's like
you don't get to eat snacks and [ __ ] you
can't drink this all being said i don't
want to go to prison but if you have to
go this way like the end of this episode
bring them in
no but it really is uh i don't know man
it's here's the thing it's like people
are they're sacrificial lambs you know
like that's true i mean she was made an
example of you know and
bad time to you know to be super
privileged and right and not really be
like yeah i [ __ ] it it's hard it's
also hard though when you're the the
sacrificial person to be like i [ __ ]
up because you usually are made an
example of yeah yeah for sure yeah and i
think they know that and their lawyer
tells them that and they go all right
look look you're a hot white woman in
her 50s you're rich as [ __ ] it's the
height of blm it looks good it's optics
yeah a lot of things are optics yeah
we're learning
i mean still better to be loyal than
george floyd let's be real
she got off easy
yeah yeah how's she doing is she out
when are we going to get the laurie
laughlin uh prison porn
[Laughter]
i want to see it i want to see it it's
called a full house
that's actually the new the new season
of orange and new black is uh exactly
that
that'd be a great 80s movie too the
husband's annoyed with his kids and his
wife and he's like i'll go to jail yeah
i'll get away yeah oh that sounds like
an 80s it does yeah
what's his name uh what's the guy who's
in soul man oh
see thomas just talking about that did
you guys watch that when you were
getting like of course
you think it yeah ruled when you were a
kid i remember being like this is
hilarious and then and then you grow up
and you're like this is not
crazy it's not a good film and i'm
shocked it was made even in the eight
yes it was too late this is backwards
for the 80s
that right you're doing blackface it's
always part of an experiment i'm like
yeah but you can't do blackface this is
that really probably
have you seen see thomas hal lately he
looks great no his age what pull up c
thomas
black face is good for your skin
being rich and black
that wouldn't be [ __ ] up if you're
like it's actually the best thing for
your skin
halo doesn't look like black face i see
my girlfriend i'm like this is not
acceptable yeah oh is it kyle dunnigan
holy [ __ ] he looks pretty good he looks
great yeah he's not [ __ ] full head of
hair yep that'll do it he's not a good
picture of him he actually looks good i
mean he's on he's got good hair yeah i
mean look at that [ __ ] hair dude look
at him see that's like he's done up
everybody looks good there he looks
better than anthony michael hall
he's a handsome man
man that outsiders is just a hunk fest
huh matt dillon oh man dylan tom cruise
patrick swayze rob lowe i mean the list
goes on remember matt voltron's joke
he's like yo this girl invited me over
to watch dirty dancing two havana
knights and i go yo no swayze no wayzi
he has a couple lines yeah
i love his uh
he has that line where he's like you
know they say you catch more flies with
honey but you catch more honeys when
you're flying
just watching him do that you gotta see
a picture of him just see how funny he
is
dude
let's rank some [ __ ] yeah like some
thanksgivings and hey man we appreciate
you guys on thanks we're thankful for
you guys listening and uh you guys hope
you're having a good thanksgiving
because this is an american an important
american holiday i agree and it's a
purely american very yeah we came in we
killed the choctaw and we ate
how long are we going to be allowed to
do this uh holiday is gonna be like
columbus yeah they're gonna take this
one away
i think this might be the last one
the problem is there's no one to put it
on like columbus you put it on columbus
or whatever this is just pilgrims
pilgrimages and food yeah my family goes
hard we wear redskins jerseys
crazy these outfits these are perfect i
love how we're dressed this is fun
gobblegum
i've never done deviled eggs for
thanksgiving i gotta be honest oh my god
i gotta tell you i grew up being like a
[ __ ] deviled eggs and then i got a
little older incredible and had like a
good one and i was like oh my god these
are yeah these are way up there for me i
i don't i've never had them for i don't
think with them as a thanksgiving side
but yeah if they were they're in my
they're in the conversation come on
yeah yeah they go a long way i love them
you can't eat too many though because
you will yak yellow yeah and your shit's
gonna be all [ __ ] up you don't want
that all right what else you got here
yeah you can't rank until we've seen all
of them right uh-huh wow you're going
full powerpoint on this [ __ ]
jesus brussels sprouts i love brussels
sprouts again i don't think of them as
thanksgiving yeah i've never had a
brussels sprout on thanksgiving but a
christmas like a crispy brussels sprout
especially when you
i will say this about brussels sprouts a
little too thick there's just a there's
a little too much bite in there that i
would i prefer it was a little thinner
brussels sprouts i love them as far as
like bringing them to thanksgiving i
feel like that's what your your aunt
who's on like a health cake brings it
ain't fun yeah it's like the cool ant
brings like mashed potatoes with cheese
and like
this this might be number one for me
really i got a bone to pick with this
one
yams and the marshmallows are two once a
year
the marshmallows are too much speed ball
we already got sweet potato and now
we're going to put on marshmallow i'll
get it out if it was just
yeah but the marshmallow it makes me
sick you know what mark it's not a
[ __ ] healthy day it's a decadent
holiday i'm trying to be healthy but
this is you're putting marshmallows on a
savory the reasonable come on i don't
like it because i'm
i'm getting my sugar by i'm drinking a
bottle of wine that day that's a day
where i'm i'm drinking red wine all day
having marshmallows on top i'm like i'm
gonna have a [ __ ] sugar uh yeah and
there's an apple pie coming later with a
scoop of ice cream much you're all
making good points and i'm still [ __ ]
going hard for the yams brother i like
the yams get the marshmallow out that's
what's that we're gonna put some reese's
pieces on top of green beans where does
it end no that's not a cookie but you
know what that sounds good
my brother used to babysit me and he
would make pasta just throw m m's in
there
that's a vegetable in indiana mashed
potatoes and twix it's too much
someone handed me a twix on stage
because i ranked the number one in the
halloween rankings the woman on the
front door just handed me
this is probably number one for me
because my mom put shrimp in it and it's
okay we're talking i think mac and
cheese on its own without like a bread
crumb crunch yeah highly overrated you
need something if it's just a floppy
floppy mac and cheese without any
[ __ ] fun there it's like saggy
titties you're like what's going on
yeah they both look like an elbow noodle
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i get it you can also click on both of
them but afterwards i'll be like i wish
there was some crunch you could still
eat them when you're 90. uh
yeah
all right i like that now gravy to me i
can't eat thanksgiving without gravy i
need extra gravy double down on the
grapes is it a side no
no because you're not just eating gravy
but no i'm with you you're not eating
gravy alone got to be on the turkey and
on the mashed potatoes
not my [ __ ] i'm i'm with you turkey
can be a little dry yeah
how about so you can throw some
cranberry juice on there
some cranberry sauce juice we're
drinking cranberry juice right now some
mm-hmm speaking of skip the wine drink
hot toddies this year dude
getting this recipe from your brother
my family never did cornbread for
thanksgiving either but i i mean i love
this is like this feels like a southern
type of yeah yeah and i will say like
cornbread is incredible i mean if you
can't knock it ever great it's good so
good even like a jalapeno corn
there's a restaurant in brooklyn that
does that it's so good there was like a
southern like maybe new orleans-inspired
restaurant in brooklyn that does
jalapeno cornbread that is [ __ ]
incredible i mean it's incredible some
of them do a cheese and jalapeno and
that's pretty great yes yeah i mean it's
hard to knock
is this what is this stuff
it doesn't look like i mean hey man
stuffing for me might be number one
for me i love stuff
don't [ __ ] with stuffing there's always
too much onion in it i don't like onions
sometimes you get some like walnuts and
sausage and that stuffing oh yeah dude
i'm gonna make it i'm gonna start
stuffing for me is probably one i'm
gonna meet you with gravy my mom does
oyster stuffing it's a game oh my god
new orleans food is the best food on the
planet
but his mom's a cook too yeah oh my god
i didn't know that oh holy [ __ ]
she goes nuts
and uh now see this i don't need no this
is what is this this is cranberry
cocktail cranberry sauce gelatin yeah
[ __ ] cranberry sauce is fine but i
i'll be i'll i'll throw a [ __ ] weird
one out here i'm fine with that prepared
[ __ ] this is the one thing we can
cut corners on if we're cutting corners
there's not a big difference between
high-end cranberry uh sauce true
whatever just as long as it doesn't look
like the cannon
this looks like trash it's actually
jello salad
oh chef's got salad that's the striking
from the list jesus why is this
surrounded by cranberries why don't i
take it with my favorite really my
retirement community before i blow my
neighbor surrounded by cranberries just
so you know that's not just a prolapse
yeah yeah right this is horrible that
looks terrible get put in the trash this
is what my toilet looks like after
thanksgiving thank god for the bidet
is this green bean casserole this is my
number one like this this is my number
one stuffing two mac and cheese three
mashed potato four
yeah
you know i don't love the green bean i
like this i could kind of it's on my
lower end yes i'm getting a little scoop
of this
i got big scoops i like the
cream of mushroom sauce and i like a
vegetable mmm see i would rather i like
my mom just does green beans straight up
and i would prefer that because i'm like
i need the green on the plate it's
interesting
i feel like you're being healthy
i need a couple moments even though
they're covered in butter and [ __ ] it's
like i am still with the crunchy onions
on top yes that's a great color
it's such a decadent like you're eating
so much food this this day that you want
something green on there that you don't
feel like exactly
i want the bad stuff to be bad yeah i
want it to be so bad i want the good
stuff to be a little good
you know what that might be that might
be a [ __ ] divisive i might be this
might be the most polarizing podcast yet
but i'm going to say right now the
marshmallow crunch on top of those yams
gets all the dicks hard and all the
pussy's wet dude
i heard it here first folks
i like i like the i like the sound of
that i disagree but i like it
that's a cute croissant
is this is this a this is yes my mom
does these i've never heard it love it
thanksgiving
they call them crescent rolls
these are great i'm a big fan it's just
a french spine i mean
i'm anti-bread on this holiday what what
i love this corn i'm not dipping bread
in it
is all bread anyway stuffing is all
bread why do we need more this is where
i'm getting my bread because i don't do
the stuffing so these crescent rolls you
can make a little you can cut them in
half make a tiny little sandwich it's so
good that sounds cause those are little
too they're not really little they're
not like big croissants and they're
people
too so there's so much there and we're
talking by the way i i'm throwing
another thing out there as a side it's
not a food uh-oh sad little hot uh
thanksgiving movie
planes trains and automobiles wait we'll
get the movies
what i thought we were doing a whole
thing on that yeah don't worry
now there's your cranberry sauce that's
the cranberry i don't need it i i walk
right back it's a supporting player mark
it's essential it's not a star for me
it's like either gravy or this and i'm
taking gravy here here
agreed this one doesn't really do it for
me i'm against this i think you can have
it all it's thanksgiving this is the day
we took everything from a group of
people let's keep everything
yeah
[Applause]
yeah that's good but i take the crescent
roll over the biscuit
i mean we can't have this cornbread and
this yeah that's too much yeah i would
take the cornbread and the crescent roll
over this
biscuits are great i'm passing on this
am i i'm gonna do any of this [ __ ] but
if i were to rank i'd go i'd go
cornbread first shame the thing is the
biscuits hit the table first while
everything else is being brought out you
snack on a little butter biscuit and
then you go and grab the cornbread with
the rest of the stuff
got it
this yeah i only need one that's
excellent i mean it looks great all this
[ __ ] is crunchy i love the layers but
it's like sometimes you're at a barbecue
place and they bring [ __ ] like this out
and you're like i'm about to eat so much
sugar
i don't know if i can handle all this
exactly and that type of this type of
food i have to pace myself so much my
stomach gets [ __ ] up so fast now yeah
i can't eat like this so it's like i
gotta pick one bread and like
one really [ __ ] up thing and then one
girl i can't do all of it it's the same
with sex you know sometimes the girl
will start jerking you off and you're
like you got to stop
i want to [ __ ] you i'm going to come
yeah you can't blow me don't blow me
don't blow me you blow me it's over
yeah i'm like
you still got this hand job [ __ ]
for choking me you can't be right right
because girls are different you can do
all this foreplay and they can go like
five times in a night but once i come
i'm i'm i'm gay now
i have no interest in women baked potato
i mean look i'm i'm gonna say this right
now you can't ever go wrong with a big
wrong hey you throw some butter and sour
cream on there yeah
with a chive or a bacon bit or a little
cheese the chives
subtle but excellent now i feel like
this is going to come up but baked
potato or mashed potato that's a good
question
i prefer i might go baked yeah i think
it's controversial but a baked but
there's something about it baked with it
mashed potatoes incredible
you have a garlic mashed potatoes it's
good but you know what's really good
throwing that garlic on that baked
potato now we're talking about you
getting the skin but also there's a
combo here where if you get the skin in
the mashed potatoes that's where i like
have you ever done the scooped out baked
potato mash it put it back in the skin
i got a potato eraser just for this i'm
perfecting my uh baked potato mashed
potato recipe interesting i like where
your heads at i love it i never had a uh
private chef growing up so i didn't have
that so we got this
potato but we don't really do that we i
think maybe mash i don't know you like
the we we only oh
[Music]
the parsley the butter the pepper i
never see these though where do you get
really no my mom makes these this is
number one
they're not easy to make
you gotta slice them yeah number one
number one number one
[ __ ] incredible man is there a more
versatile vegetable than potato
it's one of those vegetables you're like
this is some imposter [ __ ] yeah
what's funny if you're trying to lose
weight you and you stick to baked
potatoes you're going to be all right
really yeah yeah yeah i thought it was a
starch i thought it was a starch but but
if you're like when i was really losing
weight like when i was the thinnest i've
ever been i would heat up a [ __ ]
potato cut it in half and just put a
bunch of pepper on it
you're going to be fine it's like it's
so low-calorie a little offensive to the
irish
they missed out on that mode yep yep yep
they [ __ ] what is this
what is this uh this i've never heard of
cabbage rolls
is this a [ __ ] five-star restaurant
this is this is uh disqualified because
that's not a thanksgiving food but as
just a food stuffed cabbage is
phenomenal phenomenal looks good right
but it's like america we're not
that's why i love like bread stuffing
and uh green bean casserole cause
there's those are like holy american
things that i've never had growing up
like my stuffing was like the
traditional like they looked at myths
from the the puritans and they were like
they used grains and cranberries in
there i never had bread red stuff okay
but this this this we can get rid of
this this is just everything it's a
normal side i don't know if this is
thanksgiving
i'll tell you like what's if i'm doing
corn these days i want that [ __ ]
vietnamese corn that street corn where
you are
the spicy mayo on that [ __ ]
that's like a mexican thing though isn't
it the lotte is i'm into like where
there's all the oh my god that's
incredible yeah i'm into that [ __ ] yeah
but yeah this is not really like corn is
great on thanksgiving but it's not like
a go-to thanksgiving mostly there's a
lot of old people there no one wants to
watch an old person with weird teeth
that's true we're doing the oh those are
actually like this cocktail weenies are
not a thing of giving food though it's
an appetizer
it's a classic app i do like it but it's
underrated giving food nah
i would hold off and wait for the real
real meal listen if you come from a
broken home your dad's trying to cook
something that's true that's true he's
like your mom will call me back at home
come on
apartments temporary i'm gonna get a
house i'm not gonna live in a motel
forever get out you can trust me
in some countries
we're all mad at mark for doing [ __ ]
uh
feminine good good holiday good holiday
meal though mark what the [ __ ] please
never do fed knight did you actually do
fentanyl yeah i did the great hulk but i
i wasn't playing is there fentanyl in
that supposedly i don't know it knocked
me out for like two days he was out for
14 hours mark you stopped doing fentanyl
too really yeah and i don't even do
drugs like that
it was uh molly mishap uh
and uh i it was supposedly safe uh
but it's like
it's i was like i don't have any
interest in these drugs i like booze and
that's island mushrooms like yeah that's
it and you're not at risk pills are
scary but i felt like [ __ ] like for days
after doing this and i didn't know what
it was and then it turned out it was
[ __ ] fed whoa
yeah there you go yep little finny thing
well we're glad to have you here
be careful people are [ __ ] dying
a lot of people
don't i [ __ ] have lost friends to
this [ __ ] don't do it please don't die
no thank you so take that i don't know
i might be drunk
[Laughter]
four i think we need you yeah i'll do
top fours my top four i go stuffing
yams
uh i mean [ __ ] cornbread there you can't
hard to leave cornbread off we're doing
one and then i'd probably go uh
no i don't wanna i don't consider gravy
or cranberry sauce to be a real sour
those are the three those are like
sauces so
uh
damn i don't know what else i don't know
my last one is what do you guys got
and i'm sorry green beans
uh
green bean stuffing mac and cheese
potato
all right all right i'm going scallop
potato number one yeah oh yeah that'll
be my fourth one that's number one for
me
uh
i'm gonna go after that the mac and
cheese and
my mom puts
little shrimp peas in there then i i put
that that's part of my cheeses so good
great great then uh i think i gotta go
deviled egg and then i'm gonna closing
it out with uh
with the old cornbread i think that's
the beauty of thanksgiving is whatever
it is to you really i mean yeah there's
no wrong answer i mean this is i feel
weird pretty i love deviled eggs i love
brussels sprouts i love all that stuff
but yeah i can't it's not a thanksgiving
it doesn't like rain
and for me deviled egg is like that's
only thanksgiving for me really yeah
that's like i'm only eating that on
thanksgiving
i know i know that's like a trendy thing
that's a trendy thing but when i growing
up that was a thing and now it's like i
really do love it yeah everything else i
just uh i like a lot of this stuff but i
don't
i'm not loading up the plate that hard
on thanksgiving a lot of this stuff the
i get fil i get full on mac and cheese
and like the potatoes but uh yeah it's
not like tom black's out by 11 30. i'm
drinking a bottle of wine
and uh that's most important not to get
drunk on thanksgiving
family which expedites the process
exactly
uh yeah i mean it's really
it's a great day though you're around
family it's necessary it's nice it's
good it's that's and if look if you're
one of those people listening you're not
around family we're sending love it's
it's nice but also like i get it some
people can't go home at times and hey
man i if you can't do the thanksgiving
thing i think a great substitute for me
chinese food order in chinese it's a
comfort food
i'm a jew well that's what i do that's
my christmas tree on our christmas
episode i'll be telling you all about
that i do you best believe i want to go
to knicks games and eat chinese food
yeah that's a good that's a good day
right there and i will say if you can't
be with your family just try a little
fentanyl yeah
just kick out for a couple days yeah
i will say though you can tell how close
your family is by how late you eat
thanksgiving my family has nothing to
say to each other so we're eating
thanksgiving dinner at like 9 00 a.m
like get something going you know okay
because it's so awkward so we eat dinner
early
but uh you get the football on too yeah
but my family doesn't like football
really yeah in new orleans no that's my
parents are a bunch of intellectual
nerds they don't give a [ __ ] my parents
don't like it either i'm the one who
throws the game yeah i'm watching
football uh and this year i'm not going
home because i was just there i was just
at the attic in indiana so i was like
i'll see my mom there go back for
christmas you can't go home all the time
my folks live right by me so we're doing
it but you know uh it is weird uh
i mean look i don't see him like i used
to given the last year you just don't
see people like you used to and also
we've been on the road like crazy yeah
you know thanksgiving's a special it's a
special day i know i can't wait to go
for what it represents just like the
idea of like you know to get whether
you're with family or not maybe with
friends it's it's nice i have distinct
memories of being like 12 13 14 and
coming downstairs and smelling it
already being cooked you know your mom's
going to town with the apron on and the
living room and smells up and then you
see the plates going out it's a nice
moment oh yeah it's it's definitely like
it's fun it's also my birthday around
because it's always a thursday around my
birthday sometimes it lands on it i'm
always like this is going to be great
because it's almost like christmas for
me where it's like yeah gifts on top of
the dinner it's great remember the
transition from kid table to big table
that was fun
that was big uh it sucked to be in that
middle ground though when you're like
just on the cusp of it and you're like
god
[ __ ] nerds i gotta talk to these
[ __ ] idiots we did it in boston every
year so our tradition was we would go
you know my grandparents were in boston
and then uh
and then for friday black friday we
always went to cheers for it was just
for whatever reason became a tradition
yeah because it was boston it was boss
oh that's funny we'd watched my brother
and i would watch cheers
and then we go to cheers that's great
and we'd eat like a burger but you're
like man what a gluttonous weekend yeah
yeah
but like cheers classic man classic yeah
i do remember getting to the finally
because my parents and my grandparents
were all talking about news and [ __ ] and
i was like 14
trying to get laid and get drunk and you
know my grandfather's like how about
that arafat i'm like oh yeah
saddam i didn't know anything going on
but uh that was a big deal
what what are the other thanksgiving
traditions are there i used to i used to
set up like football games and stuff
like we would play oh that's great i
forgot about playing football outside
play football and play basketball and
stuff good way to burn off that food and
yeah build up an appetizer
one year my sister and i hid behind my
grandma's house and i was like oh she'll
never find me here i just hid in a pile
of [ __ ]
that's been happening no no it was
boston oh okay and my grandma and my
grandma was like scrubbing the [ __ ] off
me i'm like man i suck i really suck a
little dumb kid
why was there a pile of [ __ ] yeah
there must have been some animal they
didn't have a head yeah i don't know
what the hell is like
i didn't know how to be out of the city
so i'm just like lying in a pile of [ __ ]
and i was like you never found me and my
sister was like yeah good job
his dad played hide and seek too and uh
really hit
[Laughter]
do i love uh
plains trains is the is the oh you can't
be you know why it's funny as [ __ ] and
it has it's got the heart
which really puts it over the edge and
the real article
you know what movie
underrated i think
dutch people watch dutch i don't know
when christopher yes
it was hilarious was that a young ethan
embry or michael is that on the list i
believe it was ethan randall sorry well
johnny is producing
is fantastic so funny man he um married
with children was hilarious
and i wasn't married with children dude
i loved uh both of them i was a huge
rose roseanne is really
really well for whatever reason
married with children was the one that
hit me married with children was like
family guy level funny oh yeah like but
it was like at that time it was live
action and you were like how is this so
[ __ ] funny it's so dark they're so
mean it's like trashy and beautiful
but like the show was not trashy they
were all like trying to be like look at
the end of the day we all love each
other we're a good fan right and ed
o'neill was like i can't [ __ ] my wife
you know a fat woman came into their
shoes totally and it would go
and then half the show was just him with
his hands
that was a punch line let's rock
it's like who does that was that a thing
dads were doing like kind of slowly
jerking off
who wrote that i know this is a normal
family thing and they had a group called
no ma'am which didn't allow women it was
so over the top misogynist and like
degenerate it was hilarious oh and dude
i mean the kids were great david
faustina christina applegate also i love
that katie seagal is like super hot
i know you're a balding shoe salesman
and this woman's dying to [ __ ] you and
you're like oh yeah
very relatable
good show good show she was incredible a
lot of people protesting
dutch yeah i i haven't seen yourselves
as a kid yeah what's the premise he gets
stuck with a kid and he's like his
girlfriend's kid or something like that
right and then yes they hate each other
which is also funny it's like it's a
it's a bad dynamic and the kid is an
[ __ ] so you side with that o'neill a
little bit oh great look at the i love
the tag line it's like home alone with
bart simpson
that's great
that's how big the simpsons were too
they were making other taglines what uh
what what other thanksgiving movies are
there never saw this one
oliver pratt
love oliver platt
my boy uh john weisberg a boy used to
work with him that's right that's right
i've never heard of this movie ever
oh come on
my daughter is pocahontas next
[ __ ]
tomatoes has been [ __ ] thrown out
what is this [ __ ] that fits the theme a
little bit at least
yeah i think the this is the problem
with nailing down thanksgiving movies
yeah we're gonna have a lot of christmas
crosses trains it's over playing stream
is over what
the charlie brown one's not bad there
you go okay that i've heard of that's it
man
there's got to be something
i'm pulling something up [ __ ] we're
scraping the barrel it's crazy a
thanksgiving classic success
if you have a real thanksgiving movie
because uh these are brutal
man are there any others
yeah when you guys pitch this as a thing
i was like i don't think there's a lot
of thanksgiving movies really holy
bummer because it is like a very
relatable i think christmas though gets
the it's the stars that's the grumpy old
man oh there you go that's a funny i got
a wreck for you i'd never seen
i'd never seen the original bad news
bears and i watched oh i saw the plane
and it was hilarious
i love that they're kids and they're
like 11 years old but they're smoking
cigarettes and even like tayden o'neil
every kid is like yeah blowing out your
ass old man they all have like that
[ __ ] attitude they say the n word
they call it people [ __ ] i mean it's
crazy it's pretty shy it's shocking and
they're trying to rewatch them it's a
good movie walter matthau is incredible
and it's also great because they now if
they we made it which i guess they did i
didn't see it but you know they'd make
it have to make it a little too buttoned
up with a bow yeah it was a shitty guy
coaching the team yeah but he did teach
them a valuable life it's it's a it's a
nuanced character it's fun when you have
characters like that that you're like
that guy is a piece of [ __ ] yes like now
they can't do that it's like the bad
guys are like the guy in parks and
record like he's not even really a bad
guy he's like
he's just a little curmudgeonly but he's
not like racist yeah
well now you make a racist guy that's
the whole character yeah
like jack nicholson as good as it gets
we've talked about that i think but you
know like this movie i love the ending
they lose by a run but of course spoiler
alert spoilers they lose by a run but
you know at the end
the other team is like you know we still
don't think you're any good but you've
got you've got more spunk than we
thought and the littlest kid in the team
goes yeah you can take that trophy and
shove it up your ass
yeah they're cheering you're like
yeah it was fun and
it's it's true like the bad the
character is likable he's still a piece
of [ __ ] but you like him it's kind of
like archie bunker yeah you could never
have an archie bunker now but the point
is that he's a douche right that's the
whole show walter matthau is incredible
yeah he's great dude one two taking
appellant one two three from the 70s it
might be my top ten now i love it i've
never seen that i don't know it's a
[ __ ] incredible new york movie
it's the best
it's the best terrorist movie because
it's about them taking over new york
city subway train and jerry stiller is
one of the other guys
and jerry stiller and the whole movie is
them just being like
a train got hijacked by terrorists and
they're like here we go they're just
annoying they're not even worried about
the people which is realistic oh that's
great i gotta see that it's like when
somebody dies on this on the train and
you're like all right let's let's get it
moving huh yeah
so good yeah and do you have any wrecks
tom i got uh yeah i got some wrecks here
uh let me look at my little phone here i
well i have some band wrecks that
part of me is like maybe people will be
like i would never do this but i don't
know if you do there's this band that i
i saw i was at a festival in boise where
they had a comedy part and a music part
and i'd already heard of this band but i
watched this band japanese breakfast
they put on the best show i've ever
[ __ ] seen in my life like i go to
them
japanese breakfast they are [ __ ] we
talked about japanese breakfast on one
of these episodes they're going to
syllabus you get a fish for breakfast oh
yeah that's right dude what kind of
their new album is [ __ ] cool as hell
it's just like indie rock [ __ ] okay with
this woman like plays a [ __ ] gong
she's so [ __ ] cool yeah
uh
i i'm like tempted oh be sweet is
[ __ ] great uh yeah this is a great
song but it's like it's it's just she's
just a you ever just watched somebody
who's a performer on stage and you're
like god damn oh yeah oh yeah it's so
good
i love the look of this video too she's
so cool man she's been doing podcasts
and [ __ ] she's funny she's great where
are they out of do you know philly oh
our best bands are out of philly now
uh doctor dog [ __ ] rules great bam uh
this means i love mannequin [ __ ] he got
featured in miravi's town oh yeah
they're great all right
[ __ ] rules that's right
um
wait keep it on for a second i like it
[Music]
i love this this is good good music just
it's uh have you ever heard of sales
yes yeah it reminds me of sales just
kind of background nice
not too much
this is some [ __ ] i bike around in new
york too and i'm [ __ ] feeling it you
know
and the video seems funny they seem fun
yeah they are fun and uh there's a dude
who's like comedy adjacent uh my buddy
adam chat who
uh he's uh his group is called uh
landlady and he did our podcast and he's
been touring with them and watching him
on stage he we were just talking to him
i was like hey what's going on man i'm
drinking a beer we're having a nice time
and then he goes on stage and he's
[ __ ] incredible and i was like oh my
god
this must be how like
you know we all do comedy yeah like
people we're just hanging out with
people and then you know you go up and
do well and you're like yeah whatever
that's a normal night for me yeah i was
like oh my god like i couldn't believe
how good he was it was crazy what's this
called this is a japanese breakfast oh
landlady
yeah he's he's great man adam adam is
awesome
all right let's check out landlady i
need some new tunes
makes me forget everywhere that's got
doctor dog vibes oh yeah
driving in california
makes me forget everything that's wrong
in the places that are not part of
california
[Applause]
oh before i forget also
biscoffs
[Music]
listening to you guys talking about
[ __ ] cops i'm always like yelling at my
[ __ ] phone
i love [ __ ] cops in a coffee that's
dipping it into coffee it's it's special
it's too hard it's too messy it's all
crumbs ah they're the packages grabbing
your dick
it's brutal hate a biscuit
all right land lady there you go good
you didn't do them good right what do
you have a wreck mark do i i don't know
if i do actually i might have another if
you don't yeah please i'm not i'm not
good with wrecks
yeah
there you go
if this is going to be my day this is
going to be my day
might as
well
um oh i got a good wreck hit me
this one everyone should get on this
[ __ ]
everything bagel seasoning
oh i use that
yeah i have it the shaky i dude it's a
game changer it's great i'll make tuna
salad and i'll [ __ ] throw some on the
on the bottom with some avocado before i
throw the tuna salad in there so it'll
make a little avocado toast you throw a
little everything seasoning on you throw
a little red pepper flakes on there it's
[ __ ] fantastic you put on anything my
lady bought that and i put it on
literally everything
is that a trader joe's
buy you can get anything yeah okay okay
okay my taste buds are shot i just blew
them out as a kid with like tabasco and
salt and seasoning so i need i always
need a kick i don't taste anything yeah
me too well i do uh
i do the um
melinda's
honey mustard habanero sauce
that is i have to put that on everything
my [ __ ] has to be habanero or i don't
feel anything that sounds like my lady
gets mad at me because she's like i cook
all this food you just douse it in hot
sauce i'm like that's the only way
that i can feel that sauce is good it's
so good
it's so good some sharia sriracha on any
is that your go-to sriracha that's still
it depends on what i'm eating but if
it's like uh you know if i'm going with
like a thai food or something i'm going
sriracha if i'm going like you order the
thai they have that special chili
that's what made me love chipotle is
they had a special like their tomate
their red tomatoes is so it was the
first thing i tasted that i was like
i will just buy this by the bottle if
you sell it to me and they don't the
spicy one yes yeah so good so good
i know [ __ ] i don't love sriracha as
much as the next guy i grew up with all
these hot sauces and
sriracha has his own flavor too much i
know i like a franks or a louisiana or a
crystal i like pranks
the crystal and tabasco
thin
don't do it for me
grits or something like now i see where
this is supposed to live you know frank
can't be very good at something like my
go-to yeah but uh
i
eat all these [ __ ] like if i see a
hot sauce in the store that i've never
seen before that looks like it'll [ __ ]
you up like [ __ ] your life up that's
what i'm doing yeah yeah yeah yeah they
have the ones that they have at mexican
restaurants [ __ ] me i can never remember
what it is but there's like a very
specific one they have it like every
mexican restaurant oh uh pepito or
something not that that's cl that sounds
close though but it's like a squeezy
that's pretty good but i don't know the
name this one's just gonna be more
squeezy there should be more squeezing
no not valentino's but i like that too
it's one of the glass things the glasses
yeah yeah i don't know what you're
talking about how do you feel like mango
habanero
stayed on my shelf for [ __ ] months
yeah i'm not into the mango too much
fruit mango out of my pineapple yeah i
don't like mixing those things with
spices i wanted to just be i want the
heat
right on me like i yeah i love heat i do
like the challenges and [ __ ] oh really
yeah sometimes i might do that buffalo
wild wings challenge ever do you ever do
a little uh vindaloo from an indian
place oh i love it yes that's a spicy
[ __ ] dude
so it's perfect i'm on stage going on
stage i'm a gary veeder in san francisco
i'm like hey gary uh you know gary i
usually give my credit card like order
us a bunch of really good food and it's
usually and i'm usually like hey let's
go light cause we got another another
show yeah yeah and gary's like sushi and
i'm like perfect i get off stage he goes
the sushi places were closed so i called
an audible like what do you got he goes
indian i'm like [ __ ] hell gary
different into the night
no you can't do that between shows we
did oh yeah and i have no self-control
so we're just pounding
and [ __ ]
masala and uh you know
biryani and all this [ __ ] we're just all
stuffing our faces and we're just laying
there like [ __ ]
we just got laid out by the crips
right
it's the worst breath and the worst
farts too with that indian holy [ __ ] the
next morning we hit blue bottle and i
was like gary i'm gonna give me one cup
of coffee for me i'm gonna go take a
[ __ ] massive dose eckies here yeah
yeah an indian dump the worst
[Laughter]
thanksgiving episode yeah
no indian food is so [ __ ] good so
good and i like to get as spicy as i can
i think it's i'm half indian there's
part of me that's like it's like
vengeful towards my dad or something i'm
like give me the spiciest [ __ ] thing
you can i can handle it you know was the
dad indian yeah yeah my dad was in india
and he walked out yeah that's rare i
feel like it's not as rare as you think
i'm on the road i meet people
came back and he called him an indian
giver that's right that's right yeah
dude indian giver is the funniest term
there's ever been
it's so racist in that like if the
[ __ ] pilgrims took the land and then
they were like what about orlando like
you [ __ ] indian giver you said we can
have this
yeah you switched it on him that's
pretty good
pretty good move there whitey
a little played
it's like when you really raise this
term it's like when you're ball busted
you have a ball busted with a friend and
he's like hey you piece of [ __ ] you're
like
hey you fat weirdo hey man what the [ __ ]
you're doing
i feel bad how'd that happen
yeah it's a good move it's like it's
like if they called like black people
like you're a slave taker aware it's
like oh
we were
you were you were the one who did the
mean thing to us right right
[ __ ] indians always asking for more
[Laughter]
so i was thinking about this uh i don't
know if there's anything here but i
think it's kind of funny which is that i
uh i talk
i talk a lot of [ __ ] because i you know
i i get into the old cups or whatever
but uh
yeah yeah but i talk a lot of [ __ ]
especially when i'm drunk but i have no
like means to back it up i don't think i
can fight or anything like that but like
i was in a bar in indiana
and this big dude kept stomping on my
shoes and like
like i i like my shoes and i don't want
them getting stomped out good shoes i
like yeah
i like cool sneakers sometimes but i
just don't want them getting stomped on
and i was like hey man don't [ __ ]
step on my shoes anymore man and he's
kind of like what are you gonna do about
it and i have to be like
well i'm gonna make you kick my ass
that's what's gonna happen don't make me
make you kick my ass
because it's gonna be a bad night for
you all right i'm gonna you know have a
fat lip but you're gonna have a guilty
conscience
a lot of swings yeah yeah your muscles
are gonna be bloody
that's it yeah your hand is gonna hurt a
little bit
it's like such an empty threat but it's
like because i talk that type of [ __ ]
like i i rolled up i biked a lot it's a
great joke yeah it's like is that
something i like i tried it once but
it's like and it like kind of worked but
you know i get scared i don't know i
just like
the idea of me being like well i talk a
lot of [ __ ] i'm like oh maybe people
will be like well you're an [ __ ] then
but no you're not asking this guy's
stepping on your shoes and you're
calling him out so you're not really
talking about it and you're a [ __ ]
blabbermouth yeah it's perfect you
defended yourself he's the unlikable one
all right okay cool i mean he's stepping
on your shoes and going what are you
gonna do about it you have a right to be
like [ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah was he
doing it purposely like it felt like he
was trying because it was a crowded bar
it felt like he was trying to make a
point you know he's like get the [ __ ]
out of my way dominant i was like i've
been standing here for a minute you know
i'm gonna talk about it on a podcast and
put it in a solid joke for him yeah i'm
gonna wear a pilgrim outfit
i'm gonna dress in the most comically
stupid outfit i can find
and i'm gonna vent about it
to my friends yeah good bit good [ __ ]
all right well you got one i got [ __ ]
nothing dude i got [ __ ] let me see if i
have anything i i'm [ __ ] my jokes are
we doing i have one that's pretty much
working tell me what you think of this i
have a joke about do you think anyone
one of those 911 flights was wearing
noise-canceling headphones
and they were the last to know oh that's
great because to me that's a that's a
great advertisement for bose
i like the idea of a trauma like noise
canceling headphones commercial it could
be like a parents like a guy beating his
wife and the kid has noise cancelling it
i was like
don't make your kid go to therapy it's
pretty it's kind of
i'll tell you bose works oh yeah it's
weird yeah like the other ones don't
work
no you do like beats by dr dre and
you're like which is what they should
call the trauma ad
by the way let's go yeah this is coming
together
now we got a bit here
no that's good what do you got going on
all right is this anything i saw a blind
guy getting you know like holding his
dog with the leash the seeing eye dog
and the dog was kind of like leading him
into second avenue and i i like was kind
of watching this guy and i was freaking
out so i i kind of grabbed the guy and i
was like hey man watch out you're going
towards traffic and he was like get off
me i don't need your charity and then i
realized like can a blind guy really
afford to be a dick you know like i
could just pick up a stick and throw it
into the highway and the dog would go
for it you know like i don't know if you
can
yeah i could put a kick me sign on you
or whatever
and then uh you know the whole joke is
like it's a pretty good way to get out
of
picking up your dog [ __ ]
you know if you're a blind guy and you
got to seeing eye dog and seeing eye dog
[ __ ] who's picking that up and then
you could do
like uh like next time i walk my dog i'm
not gonna bring a plastic bag i'm
bringing glasses and a stick oh that's
great that's like a kerb that feels like
a baby yeah larry did that's great and
then the big punches like you didn't
pick up your dog poop i'm blind like all
right so exactly yeah but who is picking
that [ __ ] up that's a good point that's
a good point i don't know who's picking
it up and yeah if the guy yells at you
you'll be like i've never seen a sunset
and the guy's like all right all right
well that kind of sucked too like how
even if you are like the most you know
responsible blind guy what are you just
gonna feel around right right horrible
no it's impossible the dog would have to
kind of do it that should you need
another dog yeah
yeah who's picking that up because the
dog ain't doing it yeah no well
sometimes you hit a dog for trying to
eat its own poop but this time you're
kind of like have at it yeah yeah that's
true yeah yeah
but this guy was all over the place and
uh he was a dick
so that is funny though that like
yeah you can't be you we're all doing
you a favor man we're all kind of being
like yeah poke me with your sticks
that's fine you let it go you can't you
can't
but you can't like
use that and be like ah
like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] or whatever
you can't be a pick it's like we're
helping a little yeah and like do you
know how easy it would be to kick your
ass
not saying i'm gonna do it but i could
just mark's the guy from your joke now
yeah
i can bob and weave and really uh
do some damage here oh the blind guy's
like i'm gonna make you kick my ass
so we gotta go on stage together just
yeah all he hears
i'm choking out the dog
[ __ ] man this is a killer app good app
for having me y'all i will be at the
blue room in missouri which i feel like
is the club that comes up the most on
this podcast
is there yeah i'll be there uh if it's
thanksgiving weekend so friday saturday
hate your family come
hang there i'm bringing my buddy dwight
simmons it'll be a good time i'm doing
on i'll be doing all the like helium
side rooms so i can make you know oh no
500 bucks yeah
[Laughter]
the indie one is actually a good room
really yeah that's a good layout
tom is a great comment
i mean really he's been posting a lot of
[ __ ] on social media follow tom on
social media tom takar t-h-a-k-k-a-r
great comments like really prolific and
writing great stuff so make sure you
follow him he really is a is a strong
strong storm comic yeah so good joke the
[ __ ] good comic been doing it for
a while huh yeah 25 years
[Laughter]
looking through and i was like did roy
do it and i was like that's just rachel
right yeah
rachel
great episode you haven't heard the
rachel
i love rachel
rachel's so [ __ ] rachel's gotta be
regular on this because she's she killed
so hard on that episode check out her
podcast with uh jessica kierson two of
my favorites baby i'll be all over too
you can check me out in a charlotte uh
comedy zone charlotte north carolina
december 2nd through 4th i'll be the
following week in the miami improv
uh and the week after that the addison
improv in dallas and uh you know i got
magoobies and timonium maryland coming
up in january richmond virginia
sacramento a lot of stuff coming up sam
morrell.com
shows and norman where are you going to
be man
baby i'll be at the buckhead theater in
atlanta also in charlotte comedy zone
i'm at milwaukee improv
uh
new orleans i think this weekend
i don't know when this comes out and uh
let's see what else i got some fun ones
vancouver's over oh royal oak michigan
comedy castle classic city classic
castle mark mark ridley's son by the way
ryan ridley who has written the best
episodes of rick and morty wow what yes
holy [ __ ] shout out to ryan ridley
incredible mark ridley who i love mark
ridley i've worked this club for years
his son is ryan ridley who is a great
writer yeah wow that is cool man i'm
going to really talk his ear off how
deep in the rick and morty are you the
people want to know
ah let's see i'm probably about to
season in and do you like that i do i do
i like it gotta keep going man people on
the road ask me that all the time
people because you are you have a little
bit of wrecking you you're always
belching you're always
i get that a lot yeah
so i'm into it great show good writing
funny show do you watch it i have seen a
couple episodes i enjoy it i just
haven't gotten
it's a great show great show i'm
i'm watching so many shows right now
that it's tough it's successful
any wrecks any show i mean i've i just i
watched all of squid game in one day
which i don't recommend doing that yeah
i dreamt a whole new season like i i i
had terrible nightmares people were like
it's not scary and i was like what are
you [ __ ] talking about the first
episode is one of the most horrific
things i've ever seen in my life yeah
it's one it's incredible season two is
coming on an airplane who wants to pee
uh no that uh i mean mayor of east town
is one of the best
she's incredible she's oh the and the
other lady who's in it whose son is like
that yeah oh yeah
spoil anything
yeah but uh who's fantastic
family is a big part of the show i love
you know what i love on hbo too i love
the undoing i thought that was awesome
i thought it was great the lady loved it
nicole kidman hugh grant's great yeah
yeah that's true i mean succession is
the best show this is the best show it's
the best show there is not last night's
episode was good but the one before that
was unreal it was incredible incredible
i was arguing with my buddies about this
yeah the scenes with [ __ ] [ __ ] and
also tom is so funny in it
oh my god let's see with greg
i pissed off mehron because i told him
he looked a little bit like tom
i i don't know if you guys see it a
handsome guy that's what i was like he's
like he's i think he's a good guy also i
think tom is hilarious so funny yeah
those episodes between kendall and uh
where the the whole scene oh my god well
the fact that he tells the only time he
tells his son that he's got a future and
that he loves him is in the business
thing where they're seething
maybe the best moment one of the best
moments of the entire show is when he
goes to take that call
and they're just sitting at the table
together and you feel you feel all of it
and it's silent and he loves his dad but
his dad doesn't won't give him anything
and it's it's brutal and cameron
he's just trying to survive i love brian
cox so much i can't wait to read his
book because it's literally just taking
shots at celebrities
oh i didn't know that oh my god did i
not tell you these quotes i mean the
quotes in the book i got to pull them up
real quick
i mean they're like can you pull up some
of these quotes man
i'm [ __ ] lazy well let me do these
ads while you do that yeah hey we might
be drunk and excited to welcome our new
sponsor bowling branch they sent me some
sheets these things are top-notch they
feel great i sleep naked we spend a
third of our lives in bed so sheets from
bowling branch make truly special gifts
they make the highest quality sheets by
doing things the right way not the easy
way
i like them i put them on the bed the
lady came home she went in the bed and
got got naked rolled around like a pig
and [ __ ] they're the greatest she's not
a pig oh boy poland branch holds himself
to high standards across the board from
sourcing pure organic cotton to putting
workers rights first their signature hem
sheets are their all-time best seller
these babies get softer with every
single wash come in on a come in a wide
range of colors and sizes you completely
toxin free and fair trade certified it's
not just their sheets that are made the
right way their pillows bath towels and
robes are great too you got to get on
this everybody needs new sheets you
spend a lot of your life in bed get in
there treat yourself and treat your
loved ones to the new standard in
bedding from bowling branch their gifts
come wrapped and ready for their special
holiday packing order by december 19th
for guaranteed delivery by christmas
best deals of the year going on now from
november 18th to the 22nd with promo
code drunk at
bowlandbranch.com that's b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code drunk
make solutions may apply
all right so we got one more ad oh okay
and thank you for coming in tommy thanks
for having me man i gotta piss so bad
i'm gonna go go go
better help his therapy for the 21st
century better help his professional
therapy all online
what's standing in the way of you
achieving your goals figure it out with
better help we love therapy he got me
into therapy it changed my life you got
to do it but it is a hassle going all
the way up to the upper west side in
manhattan so do it online folks do it
remote do it from the comfort and
privacy your own home flexible schedule
phone calls video calls at your
convenience get a good match they will
put you in a licensed therapist who is
right for you
that's the most important part of
therapy you need to find someone you
feel like you can talk to who gets
you that's the key it's fast when you
sign up you start talking to your
therapist in less than 48 hours no
waiting around it's affordable you don't
have to be rich to pay for this and
financial aid is available damn they
cover it all and now you can send
messages to your therapist anytime
they'll get back to you in between
sessions don't like your therapist we
set you up with well you can switch
anytime for free they make it easy trust
me it helps to have someone outside your
world to talk to it's easy to schedule
affordable and won't take a load off
your shoulders over one million people
have taken the charge on mental health
join them
better help is a special offer for our
listeners
visit betterhelp.com drunk for
10 percent off your first month wow
that's better help h-e-l-p dot com slash
drunk for 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com
sign up for better help to start living
a happier life
get on it folks
so this isn't brian cox but we'll wrap
up soon but he goes he writes about
johnny depp personal personable though
i'm sure he is he's so overblown so
overrated i mean edward scissorhands
let's face it if you come on with hands
like that in pale scarred face makeup
you don't have to do anything
and he didn't
subsequently he's done less
cox has not worked with depp and turned
down a role in pirates of the caribbean
whoa
what's his beef with down he just
doesn't he's just a snob he's like an
old school you think like this amber
heard love that
oh
he plays his father in 25th hour
he's a nice lad but a bit of a pain in
the ass because he fancies himself as a
writer director
this is all from his upcoming
oh my god this is what he writes about
steven seagal as ludicrous in real life
as he appears on screen
david bowie not a particularly good
actor
he wrote about quentin tarantino he
walked out of pulp fiction but would
work with the director of ass
he walked out of pulp fiction
so this makes him seem like an [ __ ]
now but i will say this i [ __ ] love
brian cox i don't care yeah he's
incredible in that show
every movie he's in though this season
is a there's a few moments of him going
[ __ ] off where i was like all right it's
becoming a cartoon when he tells the fbi
to [ __ ] off really [ __ ] oh [ __ ] the
[ __ ] off
okay like the show is incredible i saw
uh kieran cochran on the street the
other day i thought i think he lives
near me
yeah on the street pushing a baby
carriage yeah who would sell out
like after home alone we'd all be like
kieran culkin is cool as hell now like
he was the little kid and he was fuller
he wet them yeah yeah he wet the bed
yeah
so good perfect on the show yeah great
show great show we appreciate you guys
listening we love you see us all on the
road follow tom yeah listen have a great
and happy thanksgiving we're grateful
for you make sure to subscribe to the
patreon patreon.com we might be drunk
pod you get bonus content leave us a
nice review beard year we're thankful
for your amazing holiday cocktails yes
matt peters we're thankful for the
mountain studios
you're not here but we love you too
it's a happy happy holiday and we hope
you have a great one
[Music]
[Music]
you